we thought on the boards he says we have  to get stops because we feel like and we  get stops we can get out and run on this  rocket steam harden in the paint score  the field goal and a foul is called  let's replay  [Music]  just a slight reach in by John Wall  Campello sets a screen harden drives and  lays it in that's really good I mean  John Wall forced him right and so what  is hard to do he snakes the pick gets  back to his left  the Wizards started to play some defense  that time they turned the ball over  pardon  [Applause]  harden steps back to the jump Roseville  nobody in the NBA does it any better 34  points in 30 minutes for James Harden  his squad leads by one  you know where this is going  [Applause]  unbelievable